on a beaucoup de déchets bois il y avait
déforestation d'un côté j'ai des idées
j'y vais
il est parti d'un constat simple du
tortillon les déchets nous envahissent
il a donc une idée recycler des palettes
et comme il a une formation de menuisier
il s'est mis au travail
d'abord triés les planches puis les
nettoyer ensuite opération rabotage puis
découpage en lamelles des lamelles qui
l'a collé pour obtenir un dessus de
table
tout ça avec un concept bien en tête et
que des nerfs ces privilégiés ou un
matériau ou un mode de fabrication qui a
une âme un impact écologique le plus
neutre possible c'est à dire j'ai un
matériau je fabrique à proximité de la
source de ce matériau donc l'idée c'est
aussi de préserver les ressources
naturelles en étirant les cycles de vie
de ce matériau qu'on a à portée de main
et c'est ainsi que palette devient
tables hautes ou basses vernis et cirés
avec des piats qui né dans l'esprit des
années 60
quant à ses propres déchets il valait
recyclé avec un autre concept l'économie
circulaire à terme quand je vois du
volume conséquent je ne confierai une
entreprise qui fabrique des panneaux de
bois
les copeaux sont compressés et
repartiront dans l'industrie
je résume victor fait lyon a fait un
constat il a eu une idée est un concept
reste maintenant à trouver des
revendeurs en local évidemment